mars has a north-south dichotomy in
other words it's a distorted planet
nature publishes three papers which
attempt to explain this dichotomy one of
the oldest mysteries in planetary
science I'll tell you I'm thrilled about
this because I've been working on this
problem for over 20 years and and I I
started thinking about it in a very
different place than where i'm at now by
nature publishing this paper it's going
to give the problem a great deal of
visibility everything we observe on Mars
happen since this event and in many ways
this is really kind of defined Mars as a
planet this investigation was produced
using data sets from two spacecraft the
first was the Mars Global Surveyor
spacecraft which produced this
topography model of Mars and this was a
spacecraft investigation that orbited
Mars in the late 1990s and the second
data set that we've collected was
gravity the gravity was collected from
the Mars Reconnaissance Orbiter
spacecraft which is orbiting Mars right
now I have a team of the the best
planetary gravity analysts on earth and
they're also the best gravity analysts
who study Mars and Jeff was happy to get
this data to analyze it so we've known
for a long time that Mars has what we
call a hemispheric dichotomy so the
northern half of the planet is if low
elevation and it's fairly smooth whereas
the southern half of the planet is much
higher elevation about five kilometers
higher it's very heavily cratered now
the origin of this hemispheric dichotomy
has been a real mystery in planetary
science is one of the most ancient
features on the planet and you can see
it completely dominates the topography
of Mars could this have been caused by
massive volcanic activity and conviction
within the planet could it have been
caused by something from outside there
are two theories of how it formed one is
that through mantle convection one side
of the planet the cross got send while
in the other had got thickened and
another explanation that was proposed
was that a very large impact effectively
excavated part of the planet leaving the
center crust in the north what we did
was set out to test the hypothesis that
a single large event could redistribute
the crust globally from the northern
hemisphere to the southern hemisphere
leaving behind a morphology of a basin
that's similar to what we see today
their mathematics simulates a momentous
event some 4 billion years ago this idea
of a very large impact testing it via
numerical simulations using a technique
called smooth particle hydrodynamic
where you represent the planet as
collections of particles was first
proposed to me when I was a graduate
student at Cornell by Professor Steve
Squyres I tried to do this and fail
because at the time computers weren't
fast enough to properly simulate this
event when margarita showed up here at
Caltech she took this idea and ran
simulations on a very large computer
downstairs called cetera dedicated to
understanding to your physical problems
on the earth and other planets a lot of
the work that was involved in this
project was looking at a very large
parameter space looking at different
impact energies impact velocities and
impact angles and then looking the
simulation results and seeing whether
the features that are produced by these
impacts are consistent with what we see
on Mars I was a skeptic about the
dichotomy being due to an impact but for
a good reason we produce a topographic
model for Mars which is illustrated in
this globe blue corresponds to low
elevations so here blue is not water
blue is low and if you look at the
outline here no matter how you orient it
you don't get a round structure in the
solar system most impact craters around
and the the dichotomy boundary on Mars
was just not
the conventional wisdom is that the
impact events act as an explosion with
the exception of only the most oblique
events that are depicted in this in
these experimental images here most
impact craters actually exhibit a
circular cavity what we found through
these numerical simulations is that for
very large impact the distribution of
ejecta and the remaining cavity have an
elliptical geometry very consistent with
the results that were obtained from data
by Andrews Hanna at all at MIT Jeff came
along and we started looking at the
crustal thickness and and there was the
issue of this province right here is a
province called Tharsis and Tharsis is a
large volcanic region it takes up about
a quarter of the surface area of the
planet both Tharsis and the southern
highlands are shown by high typography
but if you could look beneath the
surface you see that the structure
underneath the surface is very different
so if we look at the topography of Mars
shown here and as we unwrap the globe to
a map of Mars what we then do is we're
going to remove this Tharsis region from
the topography and you can now trace the
dichotomy boundary right across through
the Tharsis province so we can now for
the first time trace the full globally
continuous extent of the dichotomy
boundary now what surprised us
originally is that the dichotomy
boundary follows a fairly smooth path
around the planet it doesn't look at all
irregular and when we looked into this
in more detail what we found is that
this path is actually the projection of
an ellipse onto a sphere and if we take
this flat map and we collapse it back
onto a globe now we can see how the
dichotomy boundary looked before Tharsis
on this spherical planet and it still
looks your regular but if we now take
this globe and then we re oriented so
that we're looking at the center of this
lowlands basin and now just unwrap the
planets we flatten it out but this time
in a polar projection centered on the
center of this lowlands basin you can
see this elliptical shape quite clearly
well this changes the ball game
elliptical craters only occur with very
very low angle impacts essentially
nearly horizontal so
less than 10 degrees from the vertical
and I think that an impact origin for
the dichotomy of Mars is now the
simplest explanation and when I look for
explanations I like simple explanations
when I can find them and and that's what
I like about this to properly simulate
an off-axis impact one needs to execute
the simulation in three dimensions this
is very computationally expensive and to
do that we require a very large computer
where with four thousand processors we
can simultaneously explore many
different initial conditions in three
dimensions with a very large number of
particles that represent Mars what you
seeing on the screen are the results of
one of our impact simulations showing
the results of an impact event that is
compatible with the observations in
particular the color of the particles
which represents the internal energy of
the material a proxy for its temperature
some of the ejecta falls back onto Mars
another part of the EGF that goes into
orbit around Mars this is in the case of
the moon-forming event and the earth is
what formed the moon and finally there's
a small amount of material that actually
escapes Mars's gravity with greater than
escape velocity a third paper appearing
in this issue by Francis Nemo UC Santa
Cruz and colleagues consider the effects
in very high resolution simulations of
head-on impacts in two dimensions this
is in contrast to the three-dimensional
simulations we execute here where we
consider the effects of oblique impact
albeit at lower resolution this impact
was essentially the defining event in
the history of Mars I mean you're
excavating not only the crust but a
significant amount of the mantle in
nearly half of the planet and that
material is being launched out into
space and then it's landing on the rest
of the planet it's landing with enough
energy that even just that material
reacting the surface would have had a
tremendous effect this impact shaped the
current surface of Mars and the lowlands
of Mars then became the sink for
anything that flows and so water
throughout the history of Mars would
have flowed north the Phoenix lander in
fact landed in the high northern
latitudes of Mar
person has a robot arm which is
attempting to dig beneath the surface
try to identify subsurface ice and it's
quite possible that the ice beneath the
surface of Mars is ancient water that
flowed there because of the fact that
this impact occurred early in Martian
history I think the take-home message is
that the early solar system was just a
really dangerous place to be a planet
you